puede que cuando estuviera viniendo
hacia aquí muchos de vosotros hayáis
puesto fotos en las redes sociales en
facebook en twitter en instagram de que
ibais a venir bueno me incluyo no no
vais a creer de que ibais a venir a
estas charlas os habréis hecho selfish
en la puerta con el photocall y todo eso
bueno esto es normal no vivimos en un
mundo conectado en donde estamos
constantemente enviando mensajes
publicando información en internet
haciendo un montón de cosas en la red
sin embargo esto
es algo bastante nuevo porque realmente
internet no lleva tanto tiempo de hecho
el primer mensaje que se mandó a través
de internet fue hace aproximadamente 50
años y el mensaje fue l o lo en realidad
el mensaje completo y va a ser login lo
que ocurre es que en mitad de la
comunicación pues se rompió y hasta
horas después no se pudo mandar bien el
mensaje entonces realmente el primer
mensaje que se manda a través de
internet oficialmente su mensaje roto
bien sin embargo 50 años después estamos
aquí mandando parece casi magia no
estamos mandando constantemente mensajes
y bueno por lo general funciona
generamos contenido generamos
información pero hace muchísimo tiempo
que hemos perdido el control de esta
información
ahora mismo confiamos en la tecnología
para la educación para nuestro trabajo
para la sanidad para cualquier cosa que
hacemos confiamos en la tecnología bueno
para eso está la tecnología para hacer
nuestra vida más fácil y más eficiente
sin embargo hay un punto en donde se ha
vuelto un poquito magia y entonces eso
nos hace perder el control que realmente
deberíamos tener sobre esa información
os estoy acá un pequeño ejemplo nosotros
cada vez que utilizamos internet cada
vez que hacemos una búsqueda en google
publicamos nuestras fotos en la red
pública con nuestras fotos en las redes
sociales como hemos comentado antes
estamos creando no es un perfil digital
cada pasito que damos en internet es una
huella que dejamos que está ahí y que
supone información sobre nosotros de
forma que se crea un boceto de nuestra
persona en internet para que pueda
servir esto porque es importante bueno
nosotros utilizamos todas estas redes
utilizamos también a nuestras
aplicaciones de móvil un montón de cosas
y son gratuitas
que guay no todo gratis todo genial
bueno no es que sea exactamente gratis
sino que el método de pago es diferente
al que nosotros estamos acostumbrados
porque el método de pago es la
información de modo que nosotros cuando
buscamos por ejemplo cómo llegar a algún
sitio en google maps nos resulta tan
fácil porque google sabe nuestra
posición donde vivimos o donde
trabajamos nos resulta muy fácil
encontrar algo que buscamos en internet
posiblemente en la primera o segunda
búsqueda que nos sale porque google
también tiene un perfil sobre nosotros
sobre ese perfil esa huella digital que
hemos dejado dice como somos y lo que
nos gusta aquí ahora nos conectamos lo
que solemos hacer de forma que es mucho
más fácil mostrarnos el contenido que a
nosotros nos puede interesar esto parece
bastante eficiente porque nos está
ahorrando muchísimo tiempo a lo largo
del día a lo largo de las semanas a lo
largo de los años eso es cierto
hay un punto que se nos está olvidando y
es que si nosotros de todo lo que
confiamos en nuestras búsquedas o en
nuestra forma de actuar en internet está
basado en un perfil que se hace sobre
nosotros significa que hay cierta
información que se nos hace invisibles y
no es porque nadie nos la esté
bloqueando no es porque nadie nos esté
prohibiendo acceder a ella sino que
nosotros mismos nos estamos censurando
se está creando un perfil sobre nosotros
que hace que no podamos acceder a
información que a lo mejor nos resulta
más controvertida oa la que no estamos
acostumbrados es una forma de aislarnos
en nosotros mismos cuando internet se
supone que es un sitio sin barreras poco
a poco estamos construyendo un internet
mucho más individualista tenemos la
capacidad de conectarnos con cualquier
parte del mundo con cualquier persona a
nuestro alrededor y muchísimo más lejos
y decidimos encerrarnos en nuestro
pequeño mundo porque esto es un problema
no sé a lo mejor a mí me gusta mi mundo
no me apetece salirme de esa zona de
confort cuando se creó a internet se
creó con una serie de normas no escritas
creadas por como una serie de
visionarios
que ya pensaban en las implicaciones que
podría tener en un futuro y ellos
pensaron en la red como en un sitio
abierto donde el conocimiento debería
compartirse y bueno no siempre es así
existe un internet invisible a nuestros
ojos que va a decidir toda nuestra vida
digital poco a poco por ejemplo a lo
mejor mientras nosotros estamos
tranquilamente mandando un whatsapp o
tranquilamente hojeando nuestro facebook
se está generando un ataque que está
poniendo en peligro la seguridad de un
montón de personas porque no sé un
hacker
ha decidido atacar a una central nuclear
en algún país que está lejos de nosotros
saldrá en las noticias puede que sí o
puede que no a lo mejor se está atacando
a una gran empresa que incluso puede que
nosotros tengamos cierta relación con
esa empresa y a lo mejor ni siquiera nos
enteramos todo eso está ocurriendo y no
somos ni seremos conscientes si seguimos
así
existe otro punto por ejemplo hay
algunos países en donde existe una
fuerte censura de internet
nosotros tenemos bastante suerte en el
sentido de que por lo general podemos
acceder a prácticamente todo lo que
queramos aunque generalmente accedemos
casi siempre a lo mismo pero imaginaros
por ejemplo que queráis acceder a
facebook y no podéis que queréis
publicar una historia que se ha ocurrido
y no os dejan eso ocurre a diario en un
montón de países cada vez es una
realidad mucho más presente en el mundo
os voy a poner algunos ejemplos que
quizás son los más llamativos por
ejemplo a lo mejor os suena
hace unos meses el año pasado hubo un
hashtag que se puso muy de moda que es
mi tú a lo mejor son algunos ni tú yo
también en inglés es un hashtag que se
creó con la idea de que las mujeres
compartieran situaciones en donde ellas
se habían sentido que habían sufrido
machismo entonces fue muy interesante
porque muchas partes del mundo se pudo
ver qué tipo de ataques se habían
sufrido diferentes mujeres en china
había varias mujeres que querían
compartir su historia sin embargo no
podían hacerlo porque allí no se puede
acceder a facebook oa twitter a cambios
cuando entran a lo mejor en internet y
buscan facebook twitter lo que hace es
que esta página les devuelve una que se
llama sina weibo que es como una mezcla
entre facebook y twitter pero nativa de
china que ocurre que haya terminado
contenido que está bloqueado y entre
ellos estaba el contenido esté el
hashtag de mitú que es lo que se hizo
bueno empezaron a poner el hashtag bol
de arroz
y el icono de un conejito esto es porque
en chino perdonadme si alguno sabe chino
de verdad vale se pronuncia mito que se
parece mucho a la pronunciación inglesa
de mito de esta forma pudieron saltarse
la censura durante un tiempo y empezaron
a publicar un montón de historias al
cabo de unas horas se empezaron a borrar
manualmente todos esos mensajes y
desaparecieron pero esto ejemplificó muy
bien este tipo de censura por ejemplo en
otros países como turquía se intentó
hacer un bloqueo de internet parecido al
de china lo que pasa es que falló porque
fue muy repentino no fue algo progresivo
sino que de pronto se bloqueó cosas como
wikipedia youtube y otras páginas
bastante visitadas y lo que hubo fue
protestas en las calles manifestaciones
ilegales de todos los habitantes que
estaban molestos con este cambio y bueno
como el gobierno es chino hacia nada
empezaron a hacer grafitis en las
paredes poniendo pistas de cómo saltarse
la censura digital esto está ocurriendo
esto es una realidad en el mundo actual
y es innegable decir que cualquier cosa
que hacemos
en el mundo digital tiene entidad en el
mundo real si nos hacen muy difícil
pensarlo porque hemos llegado hasta aquí
de forma muy rápida pero todo lo que
hacemos importa tanto de forma digital
como de forma real bueno he llegado a
este punto
igual alguno se está poniendo un gorrito
de plata se está asustando y esas cosas
no que podemos hacer nosotros como
usuarios no somos usuarios normales
bueno si somos informáticos a lo mejor
podéis tener pistas pero nosotros como
usuarios qué
hay una tendencia a nuestro mundo actual
y también incluso en la industria de la
seguridad informática o de la
informática en general muy paternalista
en donde se deja toda la responsabilidad
de que estas cosas cambien en los
informáticos y en los analistas no es
cierto como comentábamos al principio
internet solo es posible gracias a los
usuarios internet solo en la definición
fácil y rápida de la información que
todo el mundo manejamos generamos y
controlamos en internet de modo que
vosotros como usuarios también tenéis
responsabilidad que podemos hacer pues
no tenemos dos opciones podemos entrar
en pánico irnos vas a vivir al monte no
lo recomiendo es una opción que a mí me
gustaría hacer alguna vez pero no
debería ser
podemos responsabilizarnos de nuestro
contenido significa esto que tengo que
dejar de publicar perdon publicar fotos
información de mandar mensajes ni mucho
menos la tecnología esta para que
avancemos para hacernos la vida más
sencilla pero quizá a lo mejor podemos
intentar comprender un poquito mejor
cómo funciona podemos hacer pequeños
gestos como a lo mejor salir un poco de
nuestra zona de confort y empezar a
seguir en nuestras redes sociales
aquellas cosas con las que no estamos de
todo de acuerdo pero que nos hacen
llegar a otro contenido diferente que en
un principio nosotros nos llegaríamos
saber podemos dejar en manos de
asociaciones que realmente están llenas
de profesionales relacionados con todo
esto que ponen artículos pistas o
entrevistas documentales sobre ese tipo
de cosas en donde nosotros pues podemos
firmar o podemos leer podemos
informarnos de hecho cada búsqueda que
hacemos por internet también significa
algo porque cuanto más leemos contenido
más como puntuación tiene más rango
tiene y más aparece en las
de forma que si nosotros nos esforzamos
por buscar ese tipo de contenido
diferente controvertido o alomejor
escondido pues ya estamos haciendo una
acción de modo que realmente hay
pequeñas cositas que nosotros como
usuarios también podemos hacer y esto es
como una cadena sabeis estas pequeñas
cositas que tú haces más las pequeñas
cositas que hace el vecino más las
pequeñas cositas que hace la persona que
está en la otra parte del mundo para
mejorar la situación de todas esas
personas que están sufriendo censura en
un país que está a lo mejor lejos o a lo
mejor no está tan lejos de lo que
pensamos la cuestión aquí lo que
realmente puede crear un cambio es la
empatía digital se nos olvida que todos
los usuarios no solo somos usuarios sino
personas de forma que cualquier cosa que
publicamos cualquier cosa que hacemos no
es sólo nuestra desde los demás sólo con
tener un poco de sentido común y
comprender está este precepto básico
posiblemente no será mucho más fácil
descubrir que podemos crear un internet
mucho mejor